welcome to the program we begin with
breaking news from the occupied West
Bank where Israeli forces have killed
three Palestinians and injured more than
10 others during an overnight operation
in the city of Janine
now the Israeli Army has hit Janine with
at least 10 airstrikes a convoy of
Israeli armored vehicles has also been
spotted moving towards the city's vast
refugee camp two weeks ago Janine was
the site of the largest Israeli raid in
recent years separately a fourth
Palestinian was shot and killed near
Ramallah let's go straight over to Nida
Ibrahim our correspondent in Ramallah
and just bring us up to speed at Anita
on the flash points that we really need
to be focusing on right now as the death
toll Rises and the injured now tallies
into double figures
now we're talking about a current strike
that just took place in the junior
refugee camp according to local sources
we're talking about more than 10
airstrikes since the beginning of the
Israeli uh Invasion let's call it or the
Israeli escalation that took place a
little bit after midnight now what
happened is that the Israeli forces
started shooting from Choppers missiles
towards Palestinian targets leading to
the killing of three Palestinians now as
you say the number of those who were
injured we're talking about 19 who are
wounded some of them in critical
conditions the ambulances weren't able
to get to the scene of where the injured
people were because of the Israeli
forces preventing them shooting at them
even some of those who were injured were
Medics so we are expecting the numbers
off those Palestinians to potentially
rise there is a lot of tension now in
the refugee camp as the Israelis forces
are making their way inside the refugee
camp the bulldozers are going inside now
we uh know for a a while now that the
Israeli forces have been targeting the
Janine refugee camp they say that it's a
cradle for Palestinian resistance it has
so many people who are working side by
side together to attack Israeli targets
just this year alone the Israeli Army
says that more than 50 attacks against
Israeli targets came from the junior
itself so it remains a very tense
situation engineering right now thank
you for the update neither Ibrahim there
for us in Ramallah Let's cross over to
ramikuri who's co-director of the global
engagement at American University of
Beirut joins us now from Cambridge in
Massachusetts Mr Curry always good to
have you on the program for your Insight
the focus of the Israeli military attack
seems to be Janine has been over the
past few weeks why
who also held Janine has emerged
recently in the last year or so as the
center of a series of local resistance
groups that have emerged formed and
emerged spontaneously not linked to any
of the traditional Palestinian political
groups like that her popular front or
any of those because the Israelis have
perpetuated such a vicious occupation
and the Palestinian Authority has been
so totally incompetent in providing
either leadership or assistance to the
Palestinians or protection that finally
young people groups of young men have
taken it upon themselves to create small
owned group very locally
grounded and there's several of these
now to Karam and nabus and other places
and and Janine Janine is the most
dramatic example of this and the other
thing to keep in mind that Janine has
been attacked several times before going
back to 2002 and a few years ago and
earlier this year and Janine constantly
is attacked by Israelis now with
warplanes and drones and missiles and
they've used uh almost every Arsenal
every weapon in their Arsenal and the
resistance simply keeps expanding and it
is the lesson of an occupied subjugated
people that resists it doesn't that the
Jewish people through our history uh
really taught the world in so many cases
of terrible terrible subjugation and
programs that the Jews were subjected to
and mostly in white Christian Europe and
they fought back and they fought back
and they kept fighting back and any
occupied people is going to fight back
and the Israelis don't seem to
understand that massive military force
simply breeds more sophisticated
resistance and just one last Point here
The Wider picture is the Israelis have
been doing this for about 45 and 50
years they did it in Lebanon I member of
living in Beirut when the Israelis would
attack the airport or attack the
Palestinian camps with and they came up
to late Siege to Beirut and they kept
saying this is going to put an end to
Palestinian Terror run of course it
didn't it didn't put an end to any kind
of resistance it only intensified it
then they tried it and the West Bank
they tried in Gaza and they're still
doing it in Gaza and it doesn't work the
Israelis are very smart people but
they're very stupid when it comes to
understanding the consequences of their
own occupational subjugation racism and
apartheid and of course you focus very
much though in this conversation just
now on that military might yet the added
factor to this and what's emboldened the
Israelis are the settlers it has been a
very focused attack by settlers over the
past few months and and therefore the
retaliation and the resistance by the
Palestinians has also been as strong
of course the Palestinian Fighters are
attacking settlers who are legitimate
Targets on international law they're an
occupying force uh they're they're
illegally the settlers are criminals by
international law anybody who breaks the
law is a criminal Israeli settlers
including government officials and
others are criminals and the
Palestinians push back and fight them uh
and kill them if they can because this
is a war this is not a picnic where
suddenly somebody throws food at
somebody else this is a war that's been
going on since the 1930s the other point
about the settlers is the U.N statistics
that were released today
show that there have been 570 attacks
five seven zero past attacks by settlers
against Palestinians in this year alone
that's an average of three every day
they don't all get reported in the media
and almost the very few of them get
reported in the western media so the the
settlers are simply the latest
manifestation of an armed excessive
rural armed movement that Zionism has
inflicted on Palestine Sterling in the
1930s and it just keeps getting more
intense but keeps failing to achieve its
main objective of trying to pacify the
Palestinians and there's now 12 million
Palestinians they're not going anywhere
and they're going to keep fighting back
so this is a a terrible tragedy for
everybody
concerned and the latest Twist of this
the the Israeli Army today was sending
uh to SMS text messages to the cell
phones of Palestinian families inside
Janine uh telling them to be you know
informers to say if you know of any uh
terrorists or wanted person please call
this Israeli number called the Army it's
incredible the the the the gross uh
barbaric cruelty of the Israeli military
machine
combined with its failure to stop
Palestinian resistance it's really quite
astounding and this will go on and on
and on until one day the Israelis accept
the Palestinian and the Arab offer which
is still on the table to live peacefully
side by side with the Palestinian State
an Israeli Jewish State majority Israeli
with many Arabs in it and and equal
rights are all until that day comes
we're gonna see this kind of
cycle of violence and counter violence
continuing and in the meanwhile the
Palestinian Arab side if you look at
Hamas you look at Hezbollah you look at
the hotties in Yemen they're getting
more sophisticated they are it's such a
complicated web of conflict that we
continue to monitor uh thank you very
much again yet again ramikuri for your
Insight thanks for joining us from
Massachusetts thank you
thank you